basso luca roi on va commencer qu'une
catégorie que j'aime beaucoup c'est le
world du moment le cloud et rencontre
est très connu dans sa carrière
michel parce que si aujourd'hui on peut
penser que vos émissions voilà il gère
quand même les girolles ou direct michel
on sent que là on se dit voilà il gère
bien le truc ça n'a pas toujours eu
voilà il n'a pas toujours été facile
parce que tu as fais plein de directs et
pour le truck ra awards du moment le
plus fou
les extraits nommés sont ses seins serge
gainsbourg et whitney houston i say you
and i dit que vous êtes très jolis
essais son groupe du dinar cède à one de
phoques
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non
il dit que vous êtes très jolie je peux
pas vous traduire ce qu'il a dit il a
dit j'aimerais bien vous aurez déplore
pas du tout j'ai des genres et apaisée
mais il a dit il a des trois points de
cigarettes
paul hogan alias milk donne-t-il en 2010
arrive à new york
on a l'impression qu'il arrive sur une
autre planète vous en poney complètement
le message qu'est ce que je voudrais
trouver comme question pour vous à
l'intéressé vous avez dit qu'en france
est le pays où on dort le magazine et
jean pierre marielle mon tailleur
m'avait prévenu avec un costume comme ça
monsieur marielle vous allez faire un
effet mais je ne veux pas faire d'effet
moi surtout devant les milliers d'yeux
scrutateurs des inspecteurs je ne sais
pas ce qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est une
ceinture en croco bien concours oui mais
ce n'est pas à moi j'ai toujours vu des
bretelles moi je n'aime pas le croco ça
fait riche et puis pendant qu'on y est
quoi
michel c'est quoi le maroilles qui fut
pour toi alors on paris et troyes
c'est évidemment 8h15 logan polonia
crocodiles de 10 espèces d indiana jones
à l'australienne le succès mondial de
l'année il arrive jet lag melbourne
c'est loin mais à son chapeau il passe
pas l'hôtel n'a pas le temps il arriva
garé sur le plateau première question
ils sont deux mais au fond ils appellent
quand il dort au moins 15 minutes
louis d'or alors moi c'est ida s'est
réveillé mais fatigué il a dormi
profondément et c'est ouf parce que
benjamin il n'a pas les yeux ouverts
mais il dort pas et ce qui est déjà un
invité qui s'est endormi il s'entend
bien mais un peu siam et des
chroniqueurs j'ai eu de gynéco pendant
des semaines déjà mais michel ont su
vous avez reçu toutes les stars de
france mais aussi des stars du monde
entier pour le drucker awards la plus
grande star internationale
les nommer son regard
arnold schwazenegger puis cause du pic
du masque c'est drôle ce qu'ils
racontent au début qu aux etats unis
tous les agents les metteurs en scène
les producteurs du rendez vous avez
aucune chance de devenir un acteur car
vous êtes trop gros et vous êtes trop
musclée céline dion et les québécois
c'est la révélation au québec de piano
elle n'est pas passée inaperçue akale où
a eu lieu le mythe m
je vois simplement vous dire que qu'elle
ira très loin retenez bien le nom de
cette jeune fille céline dion alors je
vous donner son âge elle n'a pas encore
15 ans elle a 14 ans et vit mois alors à
15 ans au mois de mars et john travolta
la dernière fois que john est venue à
paris il parle et parle pas du tout
français et là il est essayé il ya eu ce
qui fâche temps je suis heureux d'être
là
[Applaudissements]
non si c'est moi qui fus tout ça parce
que dans les archives le gars qui
affirma nécro faut qu'ils se mettent
maintenant parce que tu vas avoir 50 50
heures de vol dont il a le temps c'est
fait l'idiot je pense à bat céline
évidemment jamais vu à londres cet été à
chaque fois qu'on se voie n'a pas oublié
rené angélil qui quand il est quand il
est mort il m'a fait remettre par céline
une lettre magnifique parce qu'on avait
toujours gardé contact
il m'avait dit je n'oublierai jamais la
france procédé c'est un timbre-poste
maintenant si vous êtes planétaire mais
ça l a jamais l'allier est très reconnu
comme julio pollueurs et c'est devenu un
peu avec tous dans le générique et voilà
et il faut jamais oublier
mais elle c'est un cas vraiment à part
c'est quelqu'un de quelqu'un d'assez
rare alors maintenant rené n'est plus là
c'est une autre vie qui commence
mais c'est vrai que elle était
terrorisée la petite héroïne et on est
allé les chercher une robe elle voulait
pas sourire elle aimait passer dans
année mais rien elle avait 16 ans qu'un
bruit pardonnez moi ils savent eux n'est
même pas une odeur bizarre on va voir le
award du moment embarrassant justement
alors regarde ces moments amour un
moment un peu gênante a connu michel
regardes tu vas pouvoir choisir entre
ses parents et beaucoup
thierry le luron en même temps
m
22 monde est d'accord c'est là
trois mois
[Musique]
merci péri merci beaucoup tiré
mohamed ali quand vous avez boxer
récemment frasier forman beaucoup de
téléspectateurs et de journalistes
spécialisés en europe se sont interrogés
sur la régularité de ces combats je vous
pose la question franchement est ce qui
vous est arrivé dans votre carrière
d'avoir des propositions malhonnêtes
est ce qu'on vous a proposé de vous
acheter soit pour perdre un combat ou
pour le gagner plus tôt j'en ai beaucoup
entendu parler de ce genre de choses
mais seulement au cinéma
jamais personne n'est venu me faire ce
genre de proposition à moi
et laurent gerra je m'en souviens tu
étais pas loin céline l'acquis et kata
qu'elle partait 40 sont dans l'assiette
et il s'en est passé des choses depuis
quelle carrière tu as fait c'est puis
maintenant rené charles a bien grandi il
a fêté ses 18 ans une sera conduit tant
que j'ai des moules et le congelé l'ont
alors pichette et comment tu vas te
sortir de cette crise de fou rire tu es
obligé de venir à des téléspectateurs
pourquoi bruits incongrus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il s'est passé un truc là bas c'est la
vie il ya eu un bruit bizarre et et tout
le monde y voit là et on cherche delete
désespérément il sait qu'il va très bien
alors merci canon est ce que tu peux
nous dire d'abord je suis passé
[Applaudissements]
michel sait quoi faire le buzz
ouais c'est sûr camille ce qu est ce que
j étais arrivé dans l'émission voilà ça
je tenais bien dans les 12 coups de midi
voilà ici voilà franchement bernard
montiel
je me demande si les uv savoura chauffe
pas le voile à jouer alors c'est j'avais
oublié lindt et à vous de ma médaille
mais je pose une question assez gonflé
je demande s'il a déjà été payé pour
gagner des combats truqués c'est voici
vous avec le recul il a il m'aime ils
meurent et mis une droite je suis là ce
soir
et puis thierry blessé avec michel et
pose des questions tu crois toujours que
c'est une question gentil mais l'armée
et puis thierry bien sûr qu'il ya une
série au sous les fenêtres de mitterrand
86 ans en inde en sonar ou à ses figures
emblématiques de penser cela ni avec le
recul c'était un visionnaire tiré parce
que 35 ans rires et la rose du ps elle a
pris un coup des relais final dernier
awards c'est le moment le plus émouvant
alors bon j'étais quelqu'un de très
sensible c'est pourquoi j'ai envie de
ton qu'on termine avec trois séquences
donc d'émotion quel est pour toi le
moment qui t'a le plus ému parmi ces
trois regarde
l'autre front soir comment croire qu'il
ne sera plus sur ses plateaux qui
deviendra plus ici vous distraire comme
il le faisait avec tant de talent depuis
15 ans claude françois nous l'attendions
sur ce plateau il ya après midi pour
répéter il devait venir nous offrir
comme il faisait souvent ses nouvelles
chansons autres en soit vous le savez
n'est plus le destin est une une ampoule
ne l'a pas voulu donner dix chars il est
ici
on sera tous à une ligne
c'est bien qu'il y soit très loin
[Musique]
ap
et johnny hallyday à la jambe brasse et
issia les petites filles david l'aura
tous ceux qui sont près de johnny et qui
le pleurent ce soir elle vous savez dans
ma carrière c'est l'ong déjà j'ai vu
partir beaucoup de copains et c'est vrai
quoi là on n'a pas mis tous l'extrait
puisque même nous voilà on est très émus
quand on voit cette image et michel c
c'était 3 3 ça c'était compliqué mais
compliqué parce qu'on m'avait demandé
d'abord johnny avec qui j'avais un
rapport très particulier mavenir sous
forme de boutade un jour tu vas ferme à
l'écran et j'ai fait savait qu'on j'ai
fait ça mais cros et il a fallu que je
m'accroche pas ce que c'était tout seul
sur le plateau du journal télévisé juste
après une sophie lapix en deux heures et
demi et j'ai dit je vais pas raconter
tout ce qu'on sait sur john innés même
show tout le temps tout en voulant me
suis dit je vais raconter duchère
personnelles avec lui et voilà et ça a
été très compliqué de terminer cette
émission d'autant qu'il a envoyé un
petit texto
peu de temps avant où il m'avait dit
j'ai été jeune si longtemps que je ne me
suis pas vu vieillir donc johnny fait
partie de ma vie qui ont toujours mais
ce qui me frappe c'est que les français
non mais c'est bernard montiel je n'en
peux plus berda prochaine sortie
[Applaudissements]
sur une note plus drôle c'est que johnny
johnny était très très drôle
c'est vrai je n'étais drôle c'est vrai
génie à chaque joueur était d'engouement
dans la noce ou dans une province à
l'épée il me disait toujours quand il
m'a dit un jour à tout le monde et mika
chanteur personne ne parlera donc j'ai
appris à parler le johnny est un jour il
m'a dit comment ça se fait qu'on a eu
marre et qu'on n'a pas tout à fait la
vigueur jeudi johnny je vois pas je suis
pas je fais du sport ne sont pas la nuit
tu sais ce que c'est je travaille
beaucoup je vais les médecins chez la
prévention je suis mariée que la même
femme qui est ta copine dany les picards
entend à chaque fois on dirait qu'elle
vite quand je vais continuer de jeunes
ici me regarde je continue ma vie de con
johnny parce que johnny nous manque
encore et on a l'impression qu'il n'est
pas parti a fait pas partie c'était
facile en ces disques se vendent comme
s'il était là il a se tient au troisième
il a un sosie vocal qui remplit les
zénith